النظام الايراني يواصل حجب خدمه الانترنت
عن معظم المدن ويعتقل اكثر من 70 صحفيا
منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات
على ايران
واشنطن تضع اللمسات الاخيره لتسليم
اوكرانيا انظمه باتريو
المغرب يلاقي فرنسا اليوم في نصف النهائي
والارجنتين تتاهل الى النهائي بعد فوزها
على كرواتيا بثلاثيه نظيفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر
التقرير الوارده من ايران باستمرار خدمه
الانترنت في العاصمه طهران وعدد من المدن
الايرانيه الاخرى ولا يزال المواطنون
مشاكل في الوصول الى الشبكه العالميه
وعاده ما يقوم النظام الايراني بحجم
الخدمه عن المواطنين في فترات الاحتجاجات
لمنعهم من التواصل او نقل ممارسات الامن
الايراني القمعيه للخارج
يوصل المحتجون الايرانيون في مختلف المدن
والجامعات تحدي قوات الامن الايرانيه رغم
انتشارها المكثف الى جانب وحدات البسيج
وذلك للتمديد باعدام للمتظاهرين واستخدام
العنفي لقمع الاحتجاجات وفق ايران
انترناشونال ففي مشهد شمال شرقي ايران
تجمع المحتجون امام المسجد الذي تقام فيه
مراسم تابين الشاب مجيد رضا رحنا ورد الذي
اعدمه النظام مؤخرا رغم اغلاق قوات الامن
لباب المسجد حيث رفع المحتجون شعارات
مدهده باجراءات النظام الايراني وشهدت
مدينه جوان رود بمحافظه كرمال شاه غرب
ايران اجراءات الامنيه مشدده بعد ان تجمع
الاهالي امام مبنى قائم مقام جمال رود
وطلب باطلاق سراح رجل الدين سيف الله
حسيني كما استمرت تجمعات واضرابات الطلاب
في مختلف الجامعات الايرانيه لاحتجاجا على
عمليات الاعدام على الرغم من مصادره
الحلقات الشخصيه والهواتف المحموله لعدد
من الطلبه
نشرت لجنه متابعه اوضاع الصحفيين
المعتقلين التابعه للنقابه الصحفيين
الايرانيه قائمه النهائيه عن اوضاع 35
صحفيه تم اعتقالهم في احتجاجات ايران لا
يزالون رهن الاحتجاج وبحسب تقرير لجنه فقد
اعتقلت ايران منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات وبناءا
على تقارير رسميه وغير رسميه نحو 70
صحافيا تم الافراج عن نصفهم تقريبا بكفاله
واعلنت اللجنه انه اضافه الى هذه
الاعتقالات فقد تم استدعاء العديد من
الصحفيين
اكدت ايران انترناشونال انا قائد عمليه
محاوله اغتيال جون بولتون ومايكومبيو
المسؤولين في الاداره الامريكيه السابقه
كان القيادي في الوحده 840 التابعه للفيلق
القدس و يدعى محمد رضا الانصاري وبحسب
مصادر ايران انترناشونال كانت الخطه
الفاشله تقضي بتجنيد عميل غير ايراني
لتنفيذ عمليه الاغتيال حتى لا ينكشف دوره
عناصر النظام لكن المصادر اكدت ان الشخص
الذي تدرج او استدرج القائمين على العمليه
هو عضو في مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
اكيد مسؤول امريكيه
رساله نظام الدفاع الصاروخيه باتريوت الى
اوكرانيا استجابه لمطالب كيف
[موسيقى]
اعلنت رئيسه وزراء نيوزيلندا يا سنده اردن
ان بلادها فرده عقوبات على ايران لتزويدها
روسيا بطائرات مسيره
جديد
كشفت ان الدول الاوروبيه قليقه
او معرفه معلومات امنيه
اخفاقات عديده للقوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
رافقتها عقوبات وعزله دوليه من كل حد وصوب
لكن يبدو ان ادوات الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين لم تنذ بعد تقرير لصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز الامريكيه كشف ان بعض الدول
الاوروبيه اصبحت حذره من ان الكرملين قد
يستغل مجتمعاتها المفتوحه لتعميق محاولات
التجسس لايصال رسائل معينه او لمعرفه
المدى الذي يمكن ان تصل له الحرب في حال
تطور الصراع ليشمل دول الغربيه الدول
الاوروبيه بدورها باتت تنتج استراتيجيات
المختلفه لمواجهه روسيا فنلندا التي تمتلك
اطول حدود مع روسيا قررت منع دخول اي
مواطن روسي يحمل تاشيره سياحيه اما
النرويج فقد قررت رفع ميزانيه الدفاع ب
10% وتفكر في اعاده اي مواطن روسي الى
حدود بلاده في حين تعمل فرنسا بطرق مختلفه
لمواجه التجسس الروسي فهي تلجا حين لطرد
الجواسيس الى بلدهم وحين تعزلهم بصوره
سريه
معطيات عده ربما تدفع الكريملا للتباع
النهج نشر الجواسيس في اوروبا فربما يرتكز
بوت على ما حدث في المانيا من محاوله
انقلاب وما اظهره الدوله من هشاشه امنيه
كارضيه لمخططاته المستقبليه بضرب اوروبا
الى جانب ما يدور في اروقه دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي من انقسام في المواقف التي
تظهرها غير موحده اضافه الى قضايا الفساد
التي خرجت الى العالم في البرلمان
الاوروبيه
تحدي سياسيا واستراتيجي وراء محاولات
التجسس للكرمله وبات التهديد الروسي يتخذ
اشكال متعدده عسكريا في اوكرانيا وامنيا
في اوروبا وفق اجهزه الاستخبارات الغربيه
قال نائب وزير الخارجيه روسيه
اقترحت على واشنطن وضع سقف لعدد موظفينا
في السفارات حتى تتمكن من توزيع العمل
وفقا لتقديرها الخاص لكن هذه الفكره لم
تلقى ردا الامريكيا لغايه الان وكانت قضيه
موظفي سفارات واحده من اهم واكبر القضايا
الشركه التي نوقشت في اسطنبول الاسبوع
الماضي
نشاطنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
ناسا ستطلق قمر صناعيه لمراقبه تغيير
المناخ ورصد المياه على وجه الارض
اهلا بكم جديد بوقعه وزير الدفاع السعودي
الامير خالد بن سلمان مع نظيره البريطاني
بن ولسه اتفاق تعاونا عسكري وقال وزير
الدفاع السعودي في مراسم بساحه الخياله في
لندن من الاتفاقيه تهدف الى تطوير قدرات
وزاره الدفاع السعوديه وتوطين الصناعات
العسكريه وتعزيز الشراكه بين البلدين في
المجال العسكري والدفاعي من جانبه اشار
وزير الدفاع البريطاني الى ان اتفاق
التعاون الدفاعي مع السعوديه ركيزه هامه
لمشاعر امني نحو دعم الامن المشترك
الاقليمي
في تونس بينما توشك الحمله الانتخابيه في
الداخل على النهايه ينطلق الصمت
الانتخابيه اليوم في الخارج باعتبار ان
عمليه الاقتراع في دوائر الخارج تتواصل
على مدى ثلاثه ايام وفق الخطه التي اقرتها
الى الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات
التشريعي الاول بعد الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في تونس غابت كل المظاهر الانتخابيه او
تكاد و رغم ان الحمله التي غبيه توشيكو
على النهايه في الداخل فانها لم تشهد
التنافس المعهود في الانتخابات السابقه
اما المواطنون فقد اختلفت ارائهم بين
مساند للمصار الانتخابيه ورافض له
منتخب خطر حتى واحد ماشي يخدم البلاد كلهم
خدمه واحد النهضه دخلت نهبط الفلوس خدمه
روحه وخدمه همم جمعتها وخلتنا احنا في سفر
خلت البلاد فارغه
والمفروض عليهم
لازم نختار احمد
كل الاستعدادات التنظيميه واللوجستيه
لاجراء الانتخابات في الداخل والخارج
وكانت اخر خطواتها تامين وصول المواد
الانتخابيه الى مختلف في مراكز الاقتراع
في الانتخابات يؤكد المتابعون انها ستشكل
حجر الاساسي في طبيعه المشهد السياسيه
التونسي مستقبلنا
اجواء الانتخابات هذه المره لا تقارنه
بالاستحقاقات الانتخابيه السابقه قد تتغير
نسبيا في الساعات القادمه باعتبار الحماس
التي قد تطفو للسطح جرار عمل بعض
المترشحين او هيئه الانتخابات
لكن يبقى الرهان على هذا الاستحقاق لتحقيق
ااه المحطه الاخيره في مشروع رئيس
الانتخابات على ان تتم عمليه التصويت على
مدى ثلاثه ايام في الخارج على ان يكون يوم
التصويت في الداخل في السابع عشر من شهر
ديسمبر كانون الاول
مع دخولي في مرحله الصوت الانتخابيه في
الخارج والحصار الانتخابات التشريعيه في
ثلاث دوائر فقط من اصل 10 تتواصلوا الحمله
الانتخابيه في الداخل باهته وقد غابت عنها
جلو مظاهر التنافس في اول انتخابات
تشريعيه بعد اقرار الاجراءات الاستثنائيه
في البلاد وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
جدد امين عام الاتحاد التونسي للشغل نور
الدين النقابات تحميل العمال اثر
الاجراءات الاصلاح التي تتخذها الحكومه
مشيرا الى ان الطبقه العامله مثقله
بالاعباء الجبائيه غير المقبوله واضاف
الطبوب بان المعركه اصبحت معركه خيارات
وطنيه موضحا ان الاتحاد لن يتنازل عن
الدفاع عن حقي اعضائه بمن ان عن تجاذبات
السياسيه
عملت وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه
من الجيش دون اجراء تاديبيه مطوله بعد
الكشف عن مؤامره الانقلابيه المزعومه
الاسبوع الماضي كما فيها اعتقاله اكثر من
20 شخصا على صله بحركه اليمنيه المتطرفه
وقالت وزيره الدفاع الالمانيه
والاعتقالات الاخيره في صفوف في مواطنين
تظهر مدى اهميه توخي اليقظه والعملي بحسب
بكل الوسائل القانونيه ضد المتطرفين
واعداء الدستور واضافت بان محاربه التطرف
لها ايضا اولويه في الجيش الالماني انا
مشروع قانون وزاره
الدستور اساسا للالقاله
نصف سكان المانيا خائفون على مصير
الديمقراطيه بلدهم التي يقترب عمرها من
سبعه عقود بعد ان شلت السلطات الالمانيه
في الشهر الحالي حمله امنيه واسعه استهدفت
مجموعه ارهابيه مرتبطه بحركه مواطن راخ
اثرى محاولاتها الانقلاب على الدوله خوف
الالماني على نظامهم ديمقراطيه اظهره
استطلاع لقياس مؤشرات الراي اجراه معهد
53% من الالمان يرون بالحركه تهديدا
للديمقراطيه الدوله محصنه والاغلبيه
المطلقه من المواطنين لا يشعرون
بالديمقراطيه فحسب بل يعتقدون ايضا ان
الديمقراطيه تستحق الحمايه
الحركه التي بدات ثمانينات القرن الماضي
ويجمع انصارها بين الايمان باستمراريه
الامبراطوريه الالمانيه ورفض الاعتراف
بدوله الحاليه يتسارع سعيها لاقتناء
الاسلحه بل تلقى بعض افرادها تدريبا على
كيفيه استخدامها وفقه تقارير استخباراتيه
ومؤخرا كشفت الاجهزه الامنيه عن محاولات
لتجنيد افراد سابقين وحاليين في الجيش
الالماني رغم انها عاده ما تجذب اليها
اشخاصا يعانون من مشاكل ماليه واجتماعيه
وفقه تقارير محليه عده الحركه اليمنيه
التي فشلت في انقلابها لا يجتمع انصارها
على انتماء واحد
فبعدهم من النازيين الجدد فيما يطمح اخرون
لتعيين ما يصفونه بملك الرايه الالماني
حنان المصري العربي
الان نتوقف مع اخبار الرياضه
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الى الموجز الرياضي
اذا وصل ليونيل ميسي قيادته لمنتخب بلاده
نحو الفوز وتجاوز برفقه نجوم التانجو
منتخب كرواتيا نحو نهايه كاس العالم
بثلاثه اهداف دولار الهدف الاول لمنتخب
الارجنتين جاء من ركله جزاء وضعها ميسي
قويه في سقف المرمى عند الدقيقه الرابعه
والثلاثين ولم يمنح الارجنتينيون كرواتيا
فرصه لالتقاط الانفاس ثم اضاف المهاجم
جوليانا البريز الهدف الثاني بعده بخمس
دقائق انتهى عليه ما الشوط الاول وفي
النصف الثاني من المباراه وبعد مجهود
فردين عالي من ميسي
الذي وضعها في المرمى هدفا ثالثا التانجو
عند الدقيقه التاسعه وال 60 لتصل الى
الارجنتين الى المباراه النهائيه بانتظار
الفائز من مواجهه المغرب وفرنس
كشف مدرب اسود الاطلس وليد الرجراجي قبل
لقاء نصف النهائي امام فرنسا بان منتخب
بلاده خاض المشوار الاصعب وسيقاتم لتحقيق
هدف
نون يكون
التاريخ لا نريد الانتظار 40 سنه حتى تكون
هناك فرصه اخرى انها فرصه ثانيه لو وضع
فريق افريقيا عربي على قمه كاس العالم
ربما انا مجنون قليلا لكن البعض قال ان
افريقيا لديها خمس منتخبات بالمونديال
وعليها الاتفاق بذلك لا نحن هنا في نصف
النهائي وسنحاول بلوغ نهائي نود تغيير
العقليه هذا ما بلغت به اللاعبين نامل ان
لا يحترمنا الخاص لانهم اذا لعبوا بافضل
مستوياتهم واحترمون فسيكون الامر صعبا
خذنا المشوار الاصعب والكل توقع انه خروج
قلت في بدايه البطوله نحن بالفوز بكاس
العالم
وسنقاتل لتحقيق هدفنا
الكوسوفي
المنتخب المغربي
من الفرص للاعب في النهائيه لا احب
الحادثه عن الحماسه او العدائيه للمغرب
افضليه جماهيريه كبيره وحذرته اللاعبين
وعلينا ان نستعد لكل شيء
البيت هو ما يجمع بين الافريقاء ويضيف له
الفتى للعلاقات لكن في قطر ياتي ملعب
البيت ليفرق بين الاصدقاء مباراه فرنسا
والمغرب تحمل الكثيره من التفاصيل
تتصدر علاقه الصداقه المميزه بين مبابي
وحكيم المشهد قبل مواجهه فرنسا والمغرب
بالدوري نصف النهائي
باريس سان جيرمان هكذا متانه الصداقه
بينهما من خلال زياره تشجيع وتهنئه قام
بها مبابي لحكيم في معسكر الاسود في
الدوحه قبل وبعد مباراه اسبانيا بدور 16
لاعبان ضل يتبادلان رسائل التهنئه بعد كل
فوز لمنتخبنا الاسود والديوك في البطوله
مباراه فرنسا والمغرب تحمل خصوصيه كذلك
للثلاثي بوفال واوناحي واشرف داريه الذين
يلعبون ويتالون هذا الموسم مع انديه
فرنسيه بالاضافه
المولود في العاصمه باريس وقضى اغلب
مشواره الكروي بين سته انديه فرنسيه
تيك توك نصف المليون متابعه
حاله من الدعم لا محدود من كل اقطاب الارض
لصالح اسود الاطلس قبل المباراه التي
تفصلهم عن الكاس الغاليه امام المنتخب
الفرنسي
ثلاثون طائره و الاف مشجعين القادمين من
المغرب سيوجدون في الدوحه لمؤازره اسود
الاطلس في لقاء تاريخي بنصف نهائي كاس
العالم امام فرنسا
وتوافد الاف المشجعين على ملعب الجنوب منذ
ساعات الاولى من يوم الثلاثاء للحصول على
تذكره المباراه بعد ما تمكن اتحاد الكره
المغربي من توفير قرابه 10,000 تذكره
بالضبط
ايضا ستعلق الشاشات حيث تم تثبيت شاشات
عملاقه في بعض القاعات على غرار الشاشه
الموجوده بملعب محمد الخامس بالدار
البيضاء وايضا
وتحظى باقبال كبير من طرف الجماهير بكل
فئاتها
التاهل التاريخي لنصف النهائي مونديال قطر
منح شعورا بالتفاؤل والفقر في نفوس
المغاربه جعلهم ينسون لفتره وجيزه ظروفهم
الاقتصاديه الصعبه
في السنغال خرج العديد باعلام وقمصان اسود
الاطلس تشجيعا للانجاز المغربي
لا ما جاوبتيني زي كيف افريقيا
بلادهم الاصليه تصل النهائي
ست الميلاد
الجاليه الفرنسيه في المغرب ستعيش مباراه
استثنائيه الالاف يوجدون في المغرب وهناك
من سيعيش شعورا خاصا لانتمائه للبلدين
في كل المجالات خاصه الرياضيه
[موسيقى]
كانت هذه ابرز واخبار المونديال شكرا لكم
على حسني المتحده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وجهه الامم المتحده نداء لجمع تمويلا
بمليار ومئتين مليون دولار من اجل توفير
الرعايه الصحيه للنساء والفتيات خصوصا
المتواجدات في مناطق تشهد نزاعات مسلحه
[موسيقى]
لقي مالا يقل عن 120 شخص في العاصمه
الكونغوليه كيشه بعد ان ادت الامطار
الغزيره الى فيضانات وانهيارات ارضيه
[موسيقى]
من المقرر ان تطلق شركه سبيس اكس صاروخا
غدا الخميس من قاعده
الفضائيه في كاليفورنيا يحمل قمرا
اصطناعيا تابعا لوكاله ناسا الفضائيه
القمر مصمم لاجراء اول مسح عالمي لمياه
سطح الارض ما يساعد على القائد الضوئي من
على عواقب تغير المناخ وذلك بفضل التقنيه
متقدمه ستتيح جمعه قياسات عاليه الدقه
للمحيطات والبحيرات والمخزون مياه
الباطنيه والانهار على اكثر من 90% من سطح
الارض
في نهايه نشره نذكره بابرز عناوين
النظام الايراني يوصلوا حجب خدمه الانترنت
عن معظم المدن ويعتقل اكثر من 70 صحفيه
منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات
نيوزيلندا تفرد عقوبات على ايران لتزويدها
روسيا بالمسيرات واشنطن تضع اللمسات
الاخيره لتسليم اوكرانيا انظمه
والمغرب يلاقي فرنسا اليوم في نصف النهائي
والارجنتين تتاهل الى نهائي بعد فوزها
بثلاثيه نظيفه على كرواتيا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]